I could smell a small and I could see it
playing shooting way up in the sky you
think this is real it's like my kids my
wife was there inside a few hours before
to think that somebody not only burned
the mossman's trying to burn everything
that you believed and that no you're not
part of this American fabric
I kept thinking what is going on here
you know we live here more kids grew up
here are we wanted are we welcome is
this goodbye eviction notice when I
became aware that there was an act of
arson a hate crime I chose to offer the
keys or synagogue to the Muslim
community that was done without any
thought of religion or politics about a
decade ago our synagogue was desecrated
with SWAT stickers and Heil Hitler
so we've been through this before there
are a hundred churches in Victoria Texas
and then there's one mosque and there's
one synagogue it's easy to follow in
your own little world and bubble and yet
I would have never guessed that the
community would have responded like this
I cancelled Sunday school and I drove
over there I wanted to show month
support and solidarity for them and I
was thrilled to see hundreds of people
come out of the woodwork and and show up
for his prayer services we had
Christians Jews blacks whites gays
straights together in solidarity with
each other when the attempts are made to
divide us actually backfires and a
perpetrator
because really bans us all together as a
cohesive group I remember standing
praying together with hundreds of
community members in front of us the
charred mosque was right behind us and
we almost turned our back to the past to
the hate and you feel there is hope not
only for now but for the future
there are pouring of support as a
powerful message of healing this came
from a family in Oregon you are our
brothers and sisters never forget that
there is more love than you can see
[Music]
you
[Music]